Josephine está resolviendo el siguiente problema
para su tarea.
5 que multiplica a "x" más 7 elevado al cuadrado
esto es igual a 245.
Completa el problema
como se ve en los pasos siguientes.
Josephine realiza estos 3 pasos que tenemos aquí,
y cuando llega a la escuela el día siguiente,
su profesora le dice
que la respuesta es "x" igual a 0
y "x" igual a -14,
ella solamente llevó
que la respuesta era "x" igual a 0.
¿En que pasó cometió un error?
Y bueno aquí tenemos el paso número 1,  pero antes de fijarnos en los pasos,
quiero que tú pauses este video e intentes encontrar
la respuesta a este problema por ti mismo.
¿Ok? Una vez que
ya estoy suponiendo que pausaste del video,
vamos a ver qué dice.
En el primer paso.
Lo que tiene es esta ecuación de aquí
5 que multiplica a "x" más 7 elevado al cuadrado,
esto es igual a 245
y entonces si te das cuenta de esta
primera igualdad que tengo aquí,
a esta segunda igualdad que tengo aquí,
bueno, lo que vio Josephine
es que teníamos que dividir todo entre 5,
y lo dividió de una manera adecuada,
ya que lo hizo de ambas partes
para mantener balanceada la igualdad
dijo,
si divido esta parte entre 5 me queda solamente
"x" más 7 elevado al cuadrado,
mientras que del lado derecho de esta igualdad,
si divido 245 entre 5 ,
voy a llegar a 49
y hasta aquí vamos bien.
Ahora de esta segunda igualdad
a esta tercera igualdad
hizo el paso 2,
lo que hizo fue darse cuenta que aquí arriba tengo
"x" más 7 elevado al cuadrado,
y para convertirlo en "x" más 7,
lo que tiene que hacer
es sacar raíz cuadrada,
por lo tanto dijo,
bueno,
voy a sacar la raíz cuadrada
de este lado izquierdo
y me va a quedar la raíz cuadrada de
"x" más 7 elevado al cuadrado,
lo cual es "x" más 7
y del lado derecho
también saco la raíz cuadrada de 49.
La raíz cuadrada de 49 es 7.
y justo aquí fue donde hizo un pequeño
pero muy, muy, muy importante error.
Ella tiene "x" más 7
elevado al cuadrado igual a 49
y cuando toma la raíz cuadrada
de este lado izquierdo
le queda "x" más 7,
mientras que del lado derecho
va a tomar la raíz cuadrada,
tanto positiva como negativa
de 49
y es por eso que
"x" más 7 es igual a 7,
porque 7 al cuadrado es 49
pero también
"x" más 7 es igual a -7
porque -7 al cuadrado también es 49
y justo aquí es donde perdió
una de las soluciones.
Solamente puso que
"x" más 7 es igual a 7,
cuando realmente debería de decir que
"x" más 7 es igual a más -7,
en el paso número 2
es donde olvidó
tomarse la raíz positiva
y negativa de 49
por lo tanto fue en el paso 2,
fue en el paso 2
en donde ella
perdió la otra solución.
¡Perfecto, estamos bien!.